Wow so I'm generally not one to talk
about anything related to the personal
lives of creators of people in Hollywood
of writers directors actors whatever cuz
by and large I don't care I mean I'm not
into gossip I really truly don't care
but what's come out in WoW at the time
I'm recording this I guess about a day
ago depending on one night get this
video up it might have been a couple
days what's come out from Joss Whedon's
ex-wife in regards to things that went
on in their marriage that led to their
divorce I don't know I get the thing is
I I like so much of what Joss Whedon has
done that I feel like at least for me
for my own peace of mind I have to talk
this through and I guess you guys are
getting brought along for the ride on
this I I tend to fall very much in the
middle of the overall question and
debate of should you separate the artist
from the art and I really do treat it on
a case-by-case basis
because I think in many ways you can't
you shouldn't separate the artist from
the art because the artist is why the
art exists as it does to try and go well
look don't consider who the artist is at
all when assessing a piece of our
assumes that art exists in a vacuum but
it's not it's made by people and what
those people are and what they believe
and what they do informs their worldview
informs their creative ideas and forms
the art that they create so I I don't on
a basic level I don't believe in
separating the artists from the art I do
try and avoid condemning a piece of art
because of issues that I have with the
artist unless the issues I have have
directly seeped into the art itself so
you know that takes
buddy like HP Lovecraft who wrote some
amazing stories there's some amazing
your mythology creation you know the
entire Cthulhu Mythos n' and all that
but at the same time really really
racist guy and again part of that is a
reflection of the time he lived in and i
know there's the whole you know don't
judge by money but even for the time he
was kind of a little bit but the vast
majority of his writing that doesn't
enter into where it doesn't her into it
is awkward as heck but i think a lot of
his writing and i think a big part of
the reason why he remains as influential
as he is is the majority of sort of the
seminal pieces of his work aren't
steeped in his more egregious beliefs
that he happened to have and I also
grant these kinds of debates are a lot
easier to have when a creator when an
artist is dead because unfortunately
when they're still alive you run into
the additional issue of by supporting
this art am i financially supporting
someone who I find objectionable I'm
rambling about other artists and I guess
I'm just trying to give some some
context for my own headspace on a lot of
this so if you haven't been following so
Joss Whedon's ex-wife cakehole wrote an
I basically wrote it wrote a column
detailing basically about 15 years or so
worth of infidelity that he continually
engaged in over the course of their
marriage and that apparently he kept
from her for quite a while as well so
again I don't I don't like to delve into
you know so artists personal lives and
having an affair is very much a personal
life thing like I don't I wouldn't care
if I didn't care when it turned out that
Ben Affleck had an affair like look that
sucks that sucks for his family but I
I just I don't care so the question
becomes why why is it bothering me and
why do I feel the need to talk about
Joss Whedon having an affair or a series
of affairs as is alleged and and I don't
want to get into an argument over
whether or not what is being said is
true
the statement from Whedon side of things
is there are some inaccurate e's in her
statement but he's not outright refuting
anything directly which to me says
there's some smoke to this fire and I
don't want to linger on the on a ton on
the details of it because I don't think
they they particularly matter but the
reason that I feel the need to talk
about this is because this is a case I
think where the artists views publicly
stated views and the point of view in a
lot of his actual art is that odds with
his actions and I think cakehole herself
actually put it very well and I'm gonna
paraphrase here but she basically said
that he betrayed the very feminist
ideals that he often says that he stands
by by the fact that he forced her to be
complicit in what he was doing by not
telling her for so long so he
continually had affairs and he took away
her choice as to whether or not she
wanted to continue to be in a
relationship with someone who had issues
being faithful he did not give her that
choice he robbed her of her choice as to
whether or not she would stay with him
and try and work it out or not by not
telling her for as long as he has he
kept it all a secret and that is more
more so than just cheating you know
because cheating having an affair and I
don't want to handle wave any of that
again as uh you know oh it happens of
whatever look but the fact that he had
affairs
honestly just makes him human like many
people and again that is not me excusing
anything but that is me saying that is
not an uncommon
personal flaw when it comes to people in
Hollywood it actually is probably the
number one most common personal flaw in
terms of how early when relationships
break down but the fact that he was
apparently deceitful in it for so long
Wow and taking that choice away from
ostensibly the most important woman in
his life at the same time as he was
oftentimes kind of patting himself on
the back about how feminist he was and
how feminist his works were that becomes
a problem and it becomes a very
unfortunate one and it doesn't suddenly
make me want to like go burn my Buffy
DVD set because I do believe especially
when it comes to message material while
hypocrisy is frustrating and
disappointing and infuriating it's also
a reality of life and most people with
some form of ideal whatever that ideal
may be whether it be a feminist ideal or
a religious ideal or whatever moral
ideal they have most people do not
actually meet to their own ideals I mean
realistically we don't again we're human
in my mind it is kind of important to
just keep in mind that the messenger
being a flawed vessel does not diminish
the power of the message and I think
that's where people can often get in
trouble and become self-destructive
might be to grant a term for it but it's
kind of the only one I'm hitting on
which is that we we tear down a good
message because we found out the
messenger was not we thought or not who
they claimed to be but
a mess a good message is a good message
and a good message will deliver it is a
good message will delivered and my
feelings on this may deepen may get more
complicated if and when more details
come out in terms of whether or not his
affairs because it's alleged by cakehole
that he was having affairs with people
involved in his shows and knowing that
he was the creator and showrunner for
most of these things that does open up
the possibility of him using a position
of power as sexual leverage and we don't
know if that's the case but it's
possible that it is and if that
transpires to be the case that may
further complicate my feelings about
things but as it stands right now I am
going to continue to take in and
continue to hold in high praise the
values and the messages of female
empowerment of the importance of family
of the importance of the family that you
choose ie your friends that are
contained in things like Buffy like
Firefly like angel and I'm not at a
point personally where I'm going to
start boycotting the man's work because
again I get I generally don't do that I
mean I braid hearts so one of my
favorite movies even after everything
that's gone on with Mel Gibson still one
of my comfort food movies so at the
moment when I'm recording this I am
angrily disappointed again not because
he had an affair people in Hollywood
people the world over have affairs it
sucks it's not okay but that he would
continually and by woeful choice
live this dual life that very
deliberately undermined things that he
was putting forward not and not just I
think I think it's the thing is it's not
just in the shows like he was D would do
interviews talking about how important
strong female characterization and the
representation of strong women and
women's rights and all these other
things are to him and I'm not saying
that he's a liar and I don't think that
those things aren't important to him but
for him to push that angle so hard while
continually engaging in the behavior
that he was behaving in and very
deliberately undermining the freedom and
the choices of who was supposed to be
the most important woman in his life
yeah that's that upsets me more than
these sorts of things usually do to the
point that I actually am making a video
about it because I get normally I
wouldn't talk about this crap I don't
care but this one
there's just something frustrating about
there being a piece of art that you love
and you know that you love and when your
ability to love it becomes compromised
and that's a selfish thing I know that
because I mean the easiest way to avoid
that just stick my ears my fingers in my
ears ago to level Li and ignore the real
world and I'm not going to do that
but it's still frustrating and
infuriating and disappointing and it's
just not fun to feel that piece of art
that means something to you potentially
means a great deal to you being
tarnished by something that you have
absolutely no control over and that
sucks
and but it's worth remembering that the
tarnishment like the beauty
of the art is in the eye of the beholder
and that it can still be a force for
good and as I said I if and when the
next time I watch something made by Joss
Whedon I'll know at that point whether
or not what's come out is truly
adversely affecting my ability to view
things that that he has worked on or
touched I don't know that yet and I'm
not going to test it for a while I want
sort of the initial emotions to simmer
down a little bit more before I even
like try but yeah Joss Whedon geek God
whitening rod now this is is not gonna
be fun so what are your thoughts on all
this I mean this was a very sort of
rambling thing this is basically me kind
of just just trying to talk this out and
exorcise demons a little bit so whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a list
of the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I'm
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher we were going to be covering a
volume of Buffy Season 8 the comic book
on that then I might bump that back on
the docket for a couple years but check
that out also on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]